hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast CBD treatment of epilepsy
and autism in a mouse model of dravet
syndrome
presented by Joshua Kaplan PhD a senior
fellow in the department of pharmacology
at the University of Washington I am
Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
were delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots leopards is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box that appears on the screen
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and best offers continuing education
credits please click on continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the plastic process to obtain
your credits please join me in welcoming
dr. Kaplan I will now turn the
presentation over to him well thanks for
tuning in everyone I looking forward to
sharing with you some of the work that I
conducted in collaboration with Bill
Cattrall's lab and Nephi Stella's lab we
focused on looking at the additional
benefits of cannabidiol or CBD in the
treatment of epilepsy and autism and our
mouse model of gervais syndrome now
you're all aware that cannabis access is
booming across the country and across
the world in the United States there are
over 10 states with legal recreational
cannabis access mostly out here on the
west coast but there are an additional
24 states that have legal access to this
location
as well as sixteen states mostly
clustered down in the southeast that
have cannabidiol or CBD only laws now
cannabidiol is one of over a hundred
vital cannabinoids in the cannabis plant
and it's one of the most well studied
the other beam Delta 9 THC now THC is
that high inducing cannabinoid that is
sought after by recreational cannabis
users and it has this high inducing
effect by acting on brain receptors
known as cannabinoid type 1 and type 2
receptors or cb1 and cb2 now CBD doesn't
necessarily act directly on these
receptors but is thought to have a large
medicinal scope decimal benefits by
acting on a range of brain targets and
this contributes to the massive and
potentially exciting medicinal benefits
cannabidiol now THC also has some
additional benefits and has been known
for hundreds if not thousands of years
for having medicinal benefits of
treating things like nausea migraine
pain whereas cannabidiol also has a wide
scope of medicinal benefits including
treating things like epilepsy pain
anxiety and a whole bunch of other
disorders
now these medicinal benefits though are
not without acute side effects
necessarily THC known to induce things
like anxiety paranoia whereas high doses
of cannabidiol can induce drowsiness but
nonetheless the benefits of there are a
large degree of benefits of using
cannabis for the treatment of a variety
of disorders particularly because it has
a relatively low therapeutic index now
the therapeutic index is essentially the
difference between the therapeutic dose
so the one that's used to achieve a
given medicinal benefit compared to the
toxic dose or the one that's gonna have
adverse side effects the larger
therapeutic index is associated with the
greater a greater
on safety profile now Delta 9 THC has a
particularly low therapeutic index
especially during the period when the
brain is still developing
cannabidiol on the other hand is thought
to have a much higher therapeutic index
both during early stages of development
and later into adulthood but to be
honest this isn't all that well
characterized and something that my lab
will be seeking to identify and
characterize moving forward but
nonetheless together this suggests that
cannabis in particular cannabidiol might
be a promising therapeutic tool to treat
a variety of disorders that are
otherwise unresponsive to traditional
medications now one such disorder is a
childhood epileptic disorder known as
dravet syndrome and one famous case of
an individual with Turvey syndrome is
this young girl from Colorado named
Charlotte now Charlotte began having
febrile seizures that 8th round right
right around 8 months and this
characterizes the early stages of the
disorder now her febrile seizures
increase in both frequency and
complexity to the point that she was
having over 300 spontaneous seizures a
week now her parents tried a variety of
different traditional antiepileptic
medications and if they had no effect
and they were sometimes making the
seizures worse and it wasn't until they
essentially threw a Hail Mary and fried
a cannabis extract from a brain known as
hippies disappointment because it wasn't
getting anyone high it was rich and
cannabidiol low in THC that she was able
to get some relief for seizures and it
reduced her seizures to practically
nothing now this idea that cannabidiol
it be a promising anti epileptic tool
for treating seizures and otherwise
treatment-resistant epilepsies has been
picked up by a number of pharmaceutical
companies now Gervase syndrome is caused
by heterozygous mutation a foetidus SC
one age which encodes the voltage-gated
sodium channels a specific isoform nav
1.1 which is the dominant isoform in
inhibitory neurons in the brain the
mutations affecting these channels leads
to a reduction in brain inhibition
leading to things like epileptic
seizures and a host of additional
comorbidities and indeed gervase
syndrome is characterized by these
epileptic seizures that again begin as
febrile seizures and become more
frequent and complex over time but in
addition to these seizures they often
have a host of additional comorbidities
including autism which we're defining
here as social interaction deficits as
well as abnormal social responses as
well as cognitive impairments and
sensory integration disorders that again
are consistent with autism now recently
there has been a successful phase three
clinical trial of cannabidiol in the
form of cannabidiol extract all the
epidemics which was produced by GW
Pharmaceuticals out of London and they
created this 98% cannabidiol extract and
tested it on the spontaneous seizure
rate in a patient population in travail
syndrome and in this study that was led
by Orrin divinsky out of the New York
University School of Medicine bond the
cannabidiol just shown here in these
blue bars caused a greater median
reduction in the seizure frequency of
Gervais Center patients compared to
those treated with placebo so this is
really exciting because for once and
suggest that there's a pharmacological
tool to reduce seizures in gervais
syndrome but nonetheless it exposes a
number of important scientific questions
that we seek to answer first we'd like
to identify if cannabidiol indeed is an
effective anti epileptic tool now one of
the challenges limitations of doing
clinical studies in humans is that due
to ethical concerns
you cannot take these patients off of
their current anti-epileptics treatments
in these previous studies cannabidiol
was only used as an add-on therapy so
we'd first like to ask whether
cannabidiol can be used as a mono
therapy on its own is it effective at
reducing seizures and if it is well how
is it working what is the molecular
mechanism neural mechanism while it's
having to achieve this antiepileptic
effects and we can use techniques such
as slice electrophysiology to gain
mechanistic insight that's just not
afforded by these human trials and then
lastly you identify that it's an
effective anti electric tool can it also
be used to treat additional aspects of
the disorder our particular in level of
interest is autism so to address these
questions in the lab we first identify
the candidate gene that causes this
disorder and through genetic screening
over the last few decades it's been
identified that most if not all of the
individuals who suffer from gervase
syndrome have mutations that affect this
Sen one a gene that encodes
voltage-gated sodium channels though in
the lab we create a mutant mouse that
has a mutation to this Sen one a gene
who created a mouse with a heterozygous
mutation affecting these voltage-gated
sodium channels and then we conduct a
thorough behavioral characterization to
identify whether or not these mice
express similar behavioral phenotypes is
that observed in human population with
gervais syndrome so over the last decade
or so our lab and others has conducted
this thorough behavioral
characterization and we've identified
that these Sen one a heterozygous mice
display the spontaneous seizures that
characterized purvey syndrome now
they're most susceptible to this
spontaneous seizure rate a high
spontaneous seizure rate during this
maximum period of seizure susceptibility
between 21 and 28 days of life and
during this time they're also at greater
risk for sudden unexpected death in
epilepsy or Sudak now this interestingly
corresponds
the time in which there is a down
regulation of the voltage-gated sodium
channel isoform NAV 1.3 and coincidental
increase in the expression of n AV 1.1
channels however as I've mentioned due
to this mutation affecting the Sen 118
there is a reduction in the expression
levels of these n AV 1.1 channels this
leads to a reduction in inhibition in
the brain leading to too much excitation
causing seizures and increasing risk of
death but it also increases the risk of
additional behavioral comorbidities
including autism like social deficits
now these studies conducted by some Hanh
who's now at the Salk Institute
identified that these Sen when a minds
heterozygous mice shall reduce
sociability he tested this in a three
chamber test of social interaction where
the subject malice is placed in a
chamber and given the option to interact
either with a novel stranger mouse over
an empty pencil cup which returned the
object now wild-type mice which you can
see in these dark bars prefer to spend
their time interacting with the novel
Mouse compared to the empty cup s again
when a mice on the other hand shown in
the bluish bars are practically
indifferent they spend an equal amount
of times interacting with the stranger
Mouse compared to the empty table though
this is consistent with this autism like
social sociability deficit and lack of
motivation to interact socially they
also have cognitive deficits both in
contextual fear learning as well as
spatial memory deficits now dr. Han
looked at the behavior in a contextual
fear conditioning paradigm shown on the
left in which mice must learn to
remember contextual cues of the
environment in which they received a
fearful stimulus in this case a single
shock and mice display their memory for
the sphere by freezing so when they get
nervous or scared they freeze and it
suggests that they know that there's a
fearful stimulus present now wild-type
mice again shown in these dark bars
remember that they received this fearful
shock in this context and it's indicated
through a high percentage of freezing or
a high rate of freezing both 30 minutes
after the shock was given and a day
later
whereas stm-1 a heterozygous mice
impairments of this memory and that's
India and that's indicated by the
reduction in their percent freezing at
30 minutes and 24 hours later so they
show impairments in fear learning and
they also show impairments in spatial
learning measured using the Barnes maze
in which mice learn the location of a an
escape box and every time they go
through another trial quickly run to
that escape box if they're able to
remember where it is
now while type mice shown in these blue
circles learn where that the location of
that escape box is based on cues around
the room and therefore their escape
latency is reduced over a number of
trials indicative of intact learning
mechanisms
whereas SCM 1 a heterozygous mice have
difficulty learning the location of this
escape box and struggle to decrease
their escape latency over the number of
trials so together these data suggest
that our dire Sen 1 a heterozygous mice
which I'll now refer to as prove a mice
recapitulate these core behavioral
phenotypes that are seen in a human
Gervase injure population they have
spontaneous seizures in essentially
Mouse adolescents at which time they're
also at greater risk for sudden
unexpected death and epilepsy or sudha
and they also express additional
comorbidities such as autism like
sociability deficits and cognitive
impairments though importantly this
makes our gervais Mouse a powerful
precision medicine tool or establishing
the strong predictive validity to
test cannabidiol effects on the
phenotypes that are associated with
pervasive though the next question
becomes can we achieve behavioral rescue
using a pharmacological approach in this
case
cannabidiol and we began our
investigation by looking at the effect
of cannabidiol on the febrile seizures
that characterized the early stages of
Gervase endure
now these studies were conducted by Ruth
Weston Burke in the lab and she mimicked
these febrile seizures using a thermal
induction protocol where she heated the
core body temperature of the mouse up to
38 degrees Celsius which is about a
low-grade fever and held them there
until a seizure occurred now she found
that a single acute IP injection of
cannabidiol at 100 and 200 milligrams
per kilogram reduced both the seizure
duration and the severity of that
seizure once it occurred so this
suggests that cannabidiol on its own is
effective at protecting against the
febrile seizures that characterize early
stages of the disease but we next wanted
to test whether cannabidiol was
effective at reducing the spontaneous
seizure frequency that characterizes
later stages in travail syndrome so to
do this we injected mice twice daily
with cannabidiol at a hundred milligrams
per kilogram and measure the frequency
of spontaneous seizures during this
period of maximum seizure susceptibility
a 21 to 28 days of life now vehicle
treated mice have a high rate of these
spontaneous seizures as you can see here
in blue bars
whereas cannabidiol treated mice shown
in red have a far greater reduction in
their average seizure frequency so
together this suggests that cannabidiol
is effective at reducing both the
febrile seizures as well as spontaneous
seizures in Turvey syndrome though is
cannabidiol effective as a mono therapy
I believe that our data suggest that yes
indeed in our mouse model that has both
ebrill and spontaneous seizures that are
associated with Gervase and Norman are
consistent with what we see in human
populations
yes cannabidiol on its own in the
absence of other anti epileptic drugs
reduces the severity and duration of
febrile seizures and the frequency of
these spontaneous seizures
yes it's effective as a mono therapy but
the next question is how is it working
how is cannabidiol achieving this anti
epileptic effect and so to address this
neural mechanism use techniques such as
slice electrophysiology to gain this
mechanistic insight but before I jump in
to the mechanism I just want to point
out that in a normal brain you have a
relative balance between excitation and
inhibition which is driven by again a
relative balance between the signaling
of the main inhibitory neurotransmitter
gaba and the main excitatory
neurotransmitter glutamate this leads to
seizure free and normal behavior but
this is disrupted interface syndrome
this heterozygous mutation affecting the
sn1 aging reduces the expression of any
v 1.1 channels which again is the
dominant sodium channel expressed in
inhibitory neurons which are showing you
here in red or pink this tips the brains
excitatory inhibitory balance towards
excitation now this was identified in
our initial studies were in measured
sodium currents in survey mice finding
that in pyramidal neurons excitatory
pyramidal neurons there was no effect on
the sodium current density in those
neurons however there was a reduction in
the sodium current density and
inhibitory neurons so you can see on the
right in representative current clamp
recordings of inhibitory neurons where
were measuring the frequency of action
potentials that are elicited with
increasing amounts of current injection
curve a mice are no longer able to
sustain that high frequency of action
potential firing that's me
to dampen the excitatory transmission in
the brain at high levels of current
injections so there's this impairment in
inhibitory interneuron activity which
tips the brains excitatory inhibitory
balance towards excitation leading to
excessive excitatory transmission
through the brain causing seizures and a
host of additional behavioral
comorbidities so therefore I hypothesize
that cannabidiol was having its
antiepileptic effects by selectively
rescuing this excitability of these
inhibitory interneurons now I tested
this effect I'm using slice
electrophysiology techniques where I was
able to record changes in electrical
signals in individual neurons I was able
to record things like individual action
potentials which is a measure of cell
excitability and you can see on the Left
representative trace of action
potentials each one of these upward
deflections is an individual action
potential and that's going to be
consistent with neurotransmitter release
and I'm also able to to record afferent
neurotransmitter release from this
presynaptic neuron as postsynaptic
currents using voltage clamp techniques
and you can see on the bottom left this
representative trace of spontaneous
inhibitory postsynaptic currents which
are these downward deflections that I've
indicated with an asterisk and these
spontaneous inhibitory currents each
represent the neurotransmitter release
from the presynaptic neuron that in this
case are detected by synaptic gaba-a
receptors now I began to test the
hypothesis that cannabidiol was reducing
excitatory transmission in the brain by
recording from neurons in the vent 8
gyrus of the hippocampus and I chose
this region because the dentate gyrus is
thought to be an important date for
excitatory transmission through the
brain and breakdown of this gate the
too much excitatory transmission from
the dentate gyrus to the ca3 region of
the hippocampus is known to be
associated with seizures and both humans
as well as rodents I could think back to
your introduction to psychology course
many years ago remember the famous case
of HM who had bilateral hippocampal
lesions that left him with the inability
to form long term memories now the
reason he had that surgery in the first
place was because he was having
excessive seizure activity likely due to
the breakdown of the state so therefore
I hypothesized that cannabidiol was
having its anti epileptic effects
through reducing the excitatory output
from the dentate gyrus now I tested that
hypothesis by making whole cell current
clamp recordings of granule cells and
acutely prepared slices from survey
Center mice now consistent with my
hypothesis I found that cannabidiol at a
dose that's equivalent to the hundred
milligram per kilogram dose that had
anti epileptic affects vivo reduced the
frequency of spontaneous action
potentials though this is consistent
with the idea that it's reducing
excitatory output from the dentate gyrus
to the three region now interestingly
this effective cannabidiol was blocked
in the presence of the broad-spectrum
gaba a antagonist yeah busy therefore
suggesting that this reduction and
excitatory transmission is mediated by
an increase in GABAergic transmission
from these inhibitory interneurons so to
gain further insight into cannabidiol
effects on the inter neurons themselves
i made whole cell voltage clamp
recordings again from granule cells
these slices from the gervase under
brains and measured the effect of
cannabidiol on the frequency of
spontaneous eye PSCs in the presence of
ionotropic glutamate receptor
antagonists B&Q x and AP v just to
isolate the effect of cannabidiol on
glutamate are Timmy
be interneurons themselves now I found
that consistent with cannabidiol
increasing inhibitory interneuron
activity cannabidiol increased the
frequency of spontaneous IPS sees which
of course was blocked by gaba Zenon
but interestingly was also blocked by
the voltage-gated sodium channel
antagonist to trota toxin adjusting that
cannabidiol is increasing GABAergic
transmission in an action potential
dependent manner which is consistent
with it
increasing the excitability of these
inhibitory interneurons so to test if
cannabidiol is indeed rescuing the
excitability of inhibitory interneurons
i made whole cell current clamp
recordings of interneurons themselves
specifically the parvalbumin positive
interneurons
which are fast spiking brain cells that
provide a great deal of inhibition to
these excitatory granule cells and you
can see them labeled in the bottom right
hand corner of the screen now I tested
the effective cannabidiol shown here in
red on the frequency of evoked action
potentials with increasing amounts of
current injection and I found that
cannabidiol reduced both the real base
which is the minimum amount of current
needed to elicit a single action
potential and indicative of increased
excitability as well as increase the
maximum action potential firing
frequency and increase in current
ejection steps so this fits with the
previous data and suggests that indeed
cannabidiol is rescuing as excitability
deficit in inter neurons activation for
mice but to gain insight into
cannabidiol effects on the granule cells
themselves i conducted a similar set of
experiments where i looked at the effect
of cannabidiol and action potential
frequency in the granule cells
themselves with increasing current
injection levels now here
cannabidiol again shown here
ready had no effect on the REO base
unlike what it did the inhibitory
interneurons however it reduced the
maximum action action potential firing
frequency at these high levels of
current injection that the cell might
see for instance during a seizure so if
we take all of this information together
it suggests that D cannabidiol is
rescuing the excitability of these
inhibitory interneurons which increases
GABAergic transmission through the
granule cell and likely dampens down
this excessive excitatory output from
the dentate gyrus this competing
interpreted as perhaps reducing the or
preventing those spontaneous seizures
from occurring however like in the case
of these febrile seizures when a seizure
does occur and we see protection by
cannabidiol this could be acting by
reducing the output potential of these
granule cells themselves so it's having
dual actions both on the inhibitory
interneurons and the granule cells but
I'm most interested in how cannabidiol
is rescuing this excitability deficit in
the inhibitory interneurons so the
question becomes how is it achieving
this effect now we looked at a variety
of neural targets and many of you may
know but THC for instance is thought to
act on bb1 receptors in the brain and
through action on cb1 receptors and
activation of these receptors that
reduces calcium influx to the
presynaptic neuron and thereby reduces
neurotransmitter release so one might
hypothesize that perhaps cannabidiol was
increasing GABAergic transmission by
blocking or antagonizing these cb1
receptors and indeed it's been shown
previously to antagonize the effect of
THC upon cb1 receptors so if this was
the mechanism of action in the brain
then a cb1 receptor antagonist should
mimic the effect of cannabidiol to
increase neurotransmitter release and
occlude cannabidiol effects from having
further action on neurotransmitter
release itself so I tested this effect
using the cb1 receptor antagonist a.m.
to 8:1 and found that yes this
antagonist mimics the effect of
cannabidiol slightly by increasing
spontaneous IPS in frequency in these
granule cells however it was not able to
block cannabidiol is further action to
increase IPS see frequency so this
suggests that no this is probably not
the mechanism by which cannabidiol is
having its anti epileptic effects
because it still seems to be increasing
GABAergic transmission through an
additional mechanism now an another
target and there are many in the brain
that have been proposed for cannabidiol
to act on but one that has been recently
proposed as a potential potentially
important target for cannabidiol action
is this g-protein coupled receptor known
as g PR 55 and the endogenous ligand
here is a lipid signaling protein which
I'll just abbreviate is LPI and it's
thought that cannabidiol can antagonize
dpr 55 and antagonize or glock LP eyes
activation so so unclear though what
effect this antagonism of the dpr 55
receptor would have on inhibitory
interneurons but i hypothesized that if
indeed cannabidiol was acting as a TP r
55 receptor perhaps this was the
mechanism by which it was increasing
GABAergic transmission now again if this
is the case then a GP r 55 antagonist
alone should both mimic the effective
cannabidiol to increase GABAergic
transmission and it should block or
occlude cannabidiol further action on
any sort of the measures that we've been
looking at so far
though I conducted a similar protocol of
experiments this time using the GPR 55
receptor antagonist the ID with a bunch
of numbers and I'll just abbreviate as
CID here but indeed consistent with the
idea that CBD was acting as a GP r55
receptor antagonist it mimics the effect
of cannabidiol on its ability to reduce
granule cell spontaneous action
potentials it mimics the effect of
cannabidiol to increase spontaneous IPS
seams and mimics the effect of
cannabidiol on these excitability
measures in the inhibitory neurons
themselves and furthermore it includes
and blocks the effect of cannabidiol
from having any further action on any of
these measures together suggesting that
this cannabidiol induced rescue of
inhibitory interneuron excitability is
mediated by GPR 55 receptor antagonism
so we believe that this is the mechanism
through a GPR excuse me through which
cannabidiol is having its anti epileptic
effects which we've shown to be working
as a mod of therapy to reduce both
febrile and spontaneous seizures in our
mouse model or travail syndrome so how
is it working how is it acting as a mono
therapy through antagonism of the GPR 55
receptor and restoration of GABA a
receptor mediated signal now the next
question is if it can protect against
seizures can it also rescue additional
comorbidities associated with disease
and I chose to focus my attention on
autism interface syndrome in part
because those with dravet syndrome who
are fortunate enough to make it into
adulthood often see that the frequency
complexity of their seizures decreases
over time however they're still left
with a debilitating form of autism that
severely impacts their quality of life
both for them
as well as their caregivers though any
promising pharmacological treatment for
travail syndrome should not only target
the seizures but also the autism like
social deficits so to test the effect of
cannabidiol on autism in our mice I use
the three chamber tests of social
interaction where again our mice choose
to interact either with a novel stranger
Mouse or an object in this case an empty
pencil cog and like before wild-type
mice which are shown here on the left in
grey bars prefer interacting with the
stranger Mouse compared to the object
whereas Dravet mice treated with a
vehicle and shown here in this blue bar
are practically indifferent it spent in
an equal amount of time interacting
stranger mouths compared to the object
however low doses of cannabidiol at 10
and 20 milligrams per kilogram rescued
this sociability deficits and these mice
men bent a greeter amount of time
interacting with the stranger Mouse
compared to the object this is exciting
but we also wanted to better understand
cannabidiol effects on additional
measures of social behavior such as
social reciprocity and how they respond
to the social cues that are conveyed by
other mice so to do this we use the
reciprocal interaction test in which two
mice are placed in an open field chamber
and allowed to free leaves or the
chamber and each other and we found you
know the mice choose to explore sniff
each other they make nose to nose sniff
nose and bud sniffs is the body sniffs
and the most exciting data that came
from this experiment was that we found
that our gervais mice especially those
treated with vehicle shown here blue
engaged in a great number of these
defensive escape behaviors which you can
envision when a mouse goes to make a
social interaction and let's say makes a
nose to nose it
quickly becomes overwhelmed within that
social interaction and must quickly
escape and we see the mice quickly dart
to the opposite corner of the chamber
where they huddle there and freeze
indicative of them being scared and
anxious though these Dravet my serves
seems to be highly anxious and although
they engage in a similar number of total
social interactions they there the
quality of that social interaction is
impaired and again they're interfering
gauging in a higher frequency of these
defensive escape behaviors but
cannabidiol rescued that behavior
reducing their frequency of these
defensive escape behaviors to around
wild-type
levels so this suggests that cannabidiol
not only can rescue some of the
sociability deficits but can also
recover some of these abnormal social
behaviors that were observing in our
mice but it may also indicate that it's
having some sort of a Xia lytic or
reduce causing a reduction in anxiety in
our mice so to test the effects of
cannabidiol on anxiety we use the
elevated plus maze in which as the name
implies is simply just a maze that's
raised off of the ground and illuminated
from above now highly anxious mice
choose to spend a great amount of time
in these closed arms which are protected
proceed we are conceivably from threats
in the environment compared to the open
oven now as you expect turn of a mice
treated with our vehicle solution spend
a great amount of time in the closed arm
compared to the open arm but a single
acute dose of cannabidiol rescued this
anxiety phenotype
now these mice spend about an equivalent
of time interact spent in both the
closed aren't as well as the open are so
we find that cannabidiol not only rescue
some of the sociability deficits that
are associated with autism inter-basin
dur but also the anxiety like phenotype
so is they were able to now answer a
number of these important scientific
questions we find that cannabidiol is
effective as a mono therapy for treating
seizures as well as additional
comorbidities in pervasive term
including autism like social impairments
as well as anxiety so what might this
mean or the treatment potential of
cannabidiol in travail syndrome now it's
a very interesting and important
question because a lot of people fear
that this seizures this high frequency
of seizures that occurs during this
period when the brain is still
developing causes such irreparable
irreparable brain damage that once it
occurs you can't really rescue through
pharmacological intervention but when
our data suggests at least in our mice
is that a number of these large
behavioral comorbidities that are
associated with tribbles are merely the
result of this imbalance between
excitation and inhibition in the brain
and if you can restore that balance
through pharmacological intervention in
this case cannabidiol which is
increasing GABAergic transmission well
then you can rescue a number of these
behavioral abnormalities so this is
potentially very exciting for both
patients as well as their caregivers who
through cannabidiol might see beneficial
effects not only on reducing seizures
but also on some of the additional
comorbidities that come with the disease
so to summarize what I've demonstrated
so far we find that cannabidiol on its
own is effective at reducing the
severity of the febrile seizures observe
a symptom that characterized the early
stage of the disease and we also see
that it reduces the frequency of those
spontaneous seizures that characterized
later stages we find that this likely
occurs through a restoration in the
excitability of these new
taurine neurons which occurs through CBD
antagonism of GP r55 receptor activity
in the dentate gyrus of the hippocampus
this increases GABAergic transmission
within this important brain region
dampening the excitatory output from the
dentate gyrus and preventing those
spontaneous injures from occurring we
also find that cannabidiol in adulthood
could be a promising therapeutic
technique to also rescue some of these
behavioral comorbidities associated with
your base engine including autism like
social impairments and social anxiety so
despite these what I believe are
exciting results I think the research is
far from complete and there are a number
of future directions that I'm pursuing
currently and looking to pursue in the
future as I begin in laboratory up at
Western Washington University at the end
of the summer and they really stem from
this important question which i think is
the future elephant in the room that
many of you are probably thinking okay
we have antiepileptic effects of
cannabidiol at high doses which i've
shown you that it's effective at a
hundred and two hundred milligrams per
kilogram and ineffective at low doses at
protecting against seizures
however it's achieving this these
benefits rescuing social behaviors at
much lower doses about ten or twenty
percent of the effective dose for
treating epilepsy so how do we go about
dosing and it does present a problem now
cannabidiol because of the range of
targets that it acts on in the brain has
what seem to be like these specific
therapeutic windows for different types
of disorders you might call them the
Goldilocks zone whereas cannabidiol is
only effective at treating epilepsy in a
suit with certain doses of cannabidiol
that are different then its benefits in
treating autism and anxiety which are
only effective are effectively treated
with cannabidiol at other doses and
cannabidiol benefits and treating those
disorder
is lost when you leave that Goldilocks
zone if you will when you leave that
therapeutic window so this creates a
problem and we're looking at ways of
overcoming that now one of the ways is
through targeting the GABAergic
signaling mechanism through essentially
different or multiple mechanisms so I've
told you about cannabidiol effects to
increase spontaneous gaba release which
is mediated by synaptic gaba-a receptors
and is responsible for this traditional
phasic inhibition characterized by the
fast rise time and quick decay which
I've shown you so far but there's also a
powerful form of tonic inhibition which
is mediated by sand nap extra synaptic
gaba-a receptors that containment Delta
subunit and that's represented in this
highly filtered trace on the bottom now
these extra synaptic gaba-a receptors
are thought to be non desensitizing and
therefore contribute a large degree of
the overall inhibitory charge to the
cell and so therefore it represents a
powerful therapeutic target to increase
inhibition in disorders that are
otherwise deficient so through
potentially combinatorial therapeutic
approaches involving both cannabidiol
and perhaps modulating levels of
endogenous cannabinoids like 2ag we can
target both phasic inhibition as well as
tonic inhibition the greatly increased
that level of inhibit inhibitory
function in the brain and perhaps rescue
both seizures and autism like social
deficits using the same dose of drug so
just some preliminary data that we're
excited about we've been testing the
effects of increasing - ageing love
levels by blocking the hydrolyzing
enzyme a pH D 6 using a novel inhibitory
drug KT 182 and we find that this drug
increases the magnitude of the tonic
current in drove a mice to even almost a
greater extent than that single
wild-type mice suggesting that these
mice as well as presumably gervais
syndrome patients have a greater tonic
current targeting possibility for
pharmacological intervention the perhaps
a combinatorial approach using both CBD
as well as drugs that increase to aging
levels might be a promising therapeutic
strategy for achieving behavioral rescue
both seizures as well as other
comorbidities simultaneously in Gervais
Citroen so with that I'd like to thank a
number of people I've worked with on
this project dr. bill quatre all I'm
sponsored the initial stages of this
project i'm dr. ruth westerbrook in the
lab has been really important colleague
for bouncing scientific ideas fo she was
also the one who conducted the seizure
studies looking at the effects of
cannabidiol on both ebrill and
spontaneous seizures like to also think
my current mentor dr. Neff Estella who
I'm working in his lab now to continue
on these studies and together all of
them for helping me get to this points
where I'll be beginning a lab as I
mentioned at Western Washington
University to carry on this what I
believe important and exciting research
and cannabidiol as well as the larger
cannabis field as a whole with that
thank you for your attention
and if there are questions I believe
that I'll be getting those through email
and I look forward to answering those
alright thanks for attention
thank you dr. Kathleen for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for let's get started our first
question is why do you feel the need
to treat autism yeah that is a really
good question and look there are many
different forms of autism autism is a
spectrum disorder after all and people
can fall on all across that spectrum
individuals with dravet syndrome tend to
have a very severe form of autism to the
point that they really struggle to
function in daily life this is not the
individual who just likes to paint a lot
or read a lot of books or doing that
this is a very debilitating form that
not only can be harmful for the
individual but also is concerning for
the parents parents often report that
one of the things they're greatly
concerned about their children's they're
unable to pick up on these critical
social cues that keep them out of harm's
way and as a result struggle and can get
into accidents and other harmful things
so we're talking about a very severe
form of autism often that might have
impacts on causing self-interests
behavior and other things so we're not
talking about trying to cure all forms
of autism but help those individuals who
struggle in such a way that it severely
detracts from their quality of life
thank you the next one is did you test
the effect of CBD directly on excitatory
transmission in the brain yeah so I for
timing sake I didn't show you all the
data that we have collected but we also
looked at the effect of cannabidiol on
excitatory postsynaptic currents and
other types of excitatory measures now
we find that cannabidiol selectively
increases the excitability of inhibitory
interneuron it's not the excitatory
neurons themselves and some of those
data I already showed you but if we look
at the effects of cannabidiol for
instance on spontaneous excitatory
postsynaptic currents we do see that
cannabidiol reduces these EPS C's so
it's reducing excitatory transmission
but interestingly this effect is blocked
in the presence of GABA receptor
antagonists so this reduction in
excitatory transmission seems to be
occurring through an enhancement in
inhibitory neuron signal so yeah good
question
great thank you great how did you
measure Caesar Caesar severity is it
possible that the CBD treated mice we're
having seizures that you didn't detect
yeah that's that's a great question
yeah so we we did this all by eye so we
used a racing scale which is out of five
five being the most severe now it's
really hard to detect seizures at one
level one or two they're not these overt
physical symptoms you would have to use
an EEG and we have done EEG studies in
the lab before just never with
cannabidiol so we look at seizure
severity in our mice by just at a
seizure level of three four or five and
we see that on average cannabidiol is
reducing the severity of those seizures
from a racine level 5 to erasing level 3
3 and a half but as you note it is
possible that they're still having
seizures at a Racine scale of one or two
that were just not detecting and future
studies are we're planning future
studies where we're going to implant by
EEG electrodes to see if cannabidiol is
also reducing some of those lower
overtly undetectable seizures yeah great
question thank you here we have time for
one more question and it is is GPR 55
antagonism also the mechanism for
treating autism ah well again a good
question so we looked at the effect of
an essentially cannabidiol at the
concentration that was having
antiepileptic effects so about 16 micro
molar this is higher than the effect
that we're seeing and
we know that that 16 micro molar dose is
essentially acting through GP r55
antagonism to increase inhibitory
neurotransmitter and presumably reduce
seizures we do not look at this lower
dose of cannabidiol so we don't know if
this is the same mechanism for instance
that is contributing to the pro-social
effects that we see in anti-anxiety
effects that we see we are currently
engaging in studies in the lab where we
are injecting it this GPR 55 antagonist
drug the CI D drug I CV into the brain
it doesn't seem to cross the blood-brain
barrier so we're injecting it directly
and looking at its effects on social
behavior and some other behaviors so
don't have an answer for you directly
that on that question but it is
certainly one we are interested in
pursuing now I would just like to note
that you know there are many other
therapeutic targets by which cannabidiol
is having its action in the brain
including serotonin receptors as well as
e1 receptors cannabidiol or excuse me
cb1 receptors themselves and so other
groups have found that a lot of the azo
lytic benefits of cannabidiol in the
brain are through increasing
serotonergic cinnamon they're acting on
these 5h teen receptors so it wouldn't
necessarily be surprising if if there is
a role for GPR 55 in the pro-social
anti-anxiety effects that it's not the
only effect because presumably it's also
having this these an official behavioral
effects through actions again on
serotonin receptors and other targets
yeah that is great I would like to once
again thank dr. Kaplan for his
presentation would also like to thank
lab rules for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through June 29th
2018 you'll receive an email from
laberd's letting you know in this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that is all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye